former Vice President Joe Biden leads
the 2020 Democratic field in a key State
though he has yet to announce his run
for president I knew very early poll
shows 27% of likely Democratic
caucus-goers in Iowa picked Biden he has
a two point lead over Vermont senator
Bernie Sanders head O'Keefe is in Austin
Texas where some of the Democratic
hopefuls spoke out over the weekend heed
good morning good morning Nora the
former vice president isn't expected to
get in for a few more weeks and those
poll numbers might actually encourage
him to do so but the other Democrats
already in the race now trying to make
sure that Biden doesn't steal their
thunder 2020 contenders at South by
Southwest in Boston tried to avoid
bringing more attention to the
possibility of former Vice President
Biden getting into the fray well I have
a lot of respect for Vice President
Biden and first we want to make sure
he's getting in but I can only address
my own merit why are you better more
qualified more worthy of support than
the former vice president I'm in this
race because Washington works great for
the wealthy and the well-connected it's
just not working for anyone else
meanwhile senator Bernie Sanders
campaign Sunday in New Hampshire we are
going to complete what we started here
Sanders campaigning for president a
second time is once again forcing a
conversation among Democrats about
socialism when we came here to New
Hampshire four years ago ideas that seem
so very radical at that time well today
they are being supported by Democratic
candidates from school board to
President of the United States it's a
topic we ask Democratic primary
candidates about so in these questions
of capitalist versus socialist we put
you down as a capitalist put me down as
a capitalist if you get labeled as a
socialist well it's just wrong
former Colorado Governor John
Hickenlooper addressed the question
unfazed the nation well I'm comfortable
I'm happy let me just I'm happy to say
I'm a capitalist but I think it at a
certain point the labels do nothing but
divide us
here in Austin more than a dozen
presidential contenders made appearances
over the weekend but the eyes of the
political world will be on Washington
Tuesday morning that's when the former
vice president is set to address the
International Association of
firefighters it's a labor union that
says it would support his presidential
bid and provide him on the ground
support in places like Iowa and New
Hampshire all right ed thank you and
rest that voice thank you yes you know
home-a didn't go to bed your eye should
be in the bed closed with some tea
okay all right in our next hour momma
Gayle has your wife just called said
come up